welcome back to psbg and un sens I'm
delighted to be joined by an actress's
new book is a no hool's Bard insight
into her Stella Showbiz career it's
called behind the shoulder pads Tales I
tell my friends and as one of those
friends I've heard a lot of these Tales
Dame Joan Collins great to see you well
great to see you too P are wonderful I'm
pretty exhausted I've been on the tour
with my show behind the shoulder pads
again and this is my one day off and
only only for you P would I come
are you wearing shoulder pads tonight a
little bit of shoulder what what lurks
behind them what lurks all kinds of
Secrets I'm not going to tell you just
have to read my book you let me I just
want to start on a slightly uh serious
though but we can't ignore this
extraordinarily sad horrible story
that's come out of Israel what what do
you make of this it's barbaric I mean
it's um one of the I can't think of
anything that has upset me more other
than
911 um and I don't really want to talk
about it too much because I get upset so
if you want me to be crying during your
show go ahead no I tell you I I myself I
choked up earlier reading this new
revelation about 40 babies being killed
oh my God and some of them being
beheaded and I was like how How can any
human being do that to a baby I don't
know I I don't know it's totally
barbaric it's not a it's not the sort of
thing a human being does no it's an
animal and I I I I just um I've been
very upset ever since this happened I've
been watching all the news I've been
reading all the reports and all I can
say is that I and you know everybody
else I'm sure is just shocked and
horrified and I mean do you remember 911
yeah do you remember how I mean we heard
all those stories all the time and you
remember where you were I mean I
remember exactly where where we were and
I think that you know we'll remember
this like you remember you remember
images I mean I remember at 9/11 The
Haunting images of people jumping out of
the tow oh my God and when we realized
what it was just how everybody felt and
this time that poor young girl who's
being kidnapped from the music festival
and you know then later you see her body
and then the poor the grandmother who
survived the Holocaust and she's being
taken away and she's just stand sitting
proudly and defiantly as they take her
away to what I mean probably some
horrific murder and you think this woman
survived the
Holocaust it's just to me it's beyond
depravity uh yeah it is it's it's
barbarism it's uh it's completely vile
and hateful and I I can't think that
anybody can possibly condone it in any
way shape or form you can't if you have
answer of humanity yeah the holy
Willoughby story that's broken tonight
oh Holly we we know Holly really well
she's great fun she's a great presenter
she's been to a rough old Year anyway
with the Philip Scofield Scandal but
this is a I mean again a shocking story
that somebody has now been charged with
plotting to kidnap and and murder murder
her and her children well I I mean I
think this whole thing comes down to Too
Much social media too many people put I
mean she's there in your living room
every morning and a half hours yeah
she's pretty she's funny she's cute um
she she's not too controversial but I'm
sure that occasionally she says
something that is and um somebody gets
attached to her somebody thinks she's
you know that he can go after her it's
happened to lots of people in the public
it happened to me in a little way did it
you know um yes I got this kept on
getting these letters from this man who
was in sing sing and he said that he
wanted to marry me really and he sent me
pictures of himself saying I'm in for a
murder I didn't commit well they always
say that don't they and there was a
picture of him naked lying on his bunk
and he was a murderer well that's what
he said he didn't do it but this was
many years ago when I was a pinup girl
darling I was a pinup girl once I'm very
pinup girl now for some of
us but but but when you've look at your
career has it changed you think the
nature of that kind of attention on
particularly female stars or was it
always a bit of a problem no oh no it
has changed it's much much more before
we had to watch out for the producers
and the directors and some of the
leading men and the CEOs and the heads
of the companies and the you know the
guys who ran the studio now you have to
watch out for people on social media
that are going to try and get you and
attack you and say horrible things about
you cuz whatever you we're still human
beings we don't like people to say
nothing also
what's happened is on social media you
know I like to express opinions right
when you by the way so do you when we
had dinner together but but I know
you're careful on social media and I
know why we talked about this because
the reaction can be horrible right yes
it can and many people feel cowed now
into not wanting to express opinions I
found that so sad well cow is not n
rather a nasty word I think um smart
enough not to put yourself in the
broiling pit of hatred and Venom
which is what a lot of it is I mean
let's face it I don't go on Tik Tok
although people are saying I'd got to go
on Tik Tok Tik Tok is big is I know it's
big yeah that's you know it's the number
one news source for kids under 21 well
I'm not a kid under
21 like you're not far off yeah sure
people always say to me when they when
we post pictures of of our little
gallivanting around the world oh they
always say the same thing how does Joan
Collins look so young and what is the
answer um
good jeans handsome parents lots of face
cream keep out of the Sun and read my
book or my books yeah or your book I've
read your books yeah yeah I've read the
next one coming out I'm working on it oh
of course you are I'm working on it that
yeah there's a lot that needs to be said
well this is my 19th book behind the
show is it really yeah and it's coming
out in America on the 24th of this month
and then I've been touring with the play
not the play I mean Percy and I have
been kidding each other on the stage we
get are you coming to see us on no I
want to come to see it oh good good but
I think the other thing about you other
than your obvious uh glamour yeah is the
work ethic is what I've always loved
about you you have an incredible work
ethic where does that come from parents
uh I was very lucky I had you know the
perfect kind of nuclear family parents I
had tough um father who was um quite
strong and uh you you know very strong
and loving and sweet mother who didn't
want to do anything but look after her
children and make sure that they were
safe and that they were taken care of
and she gave us the right food and um
but my father had this got a picture of
him actually on the screen yeah yeah oh
yeah there you yeah I think Percy looks
a little bit like
him Freudian frean well we got a pet of
Percy to tell look at pery he's a
handsome man pery yeah he is he's
actually he my age isn't he I don't know
I never about yeah we're about the same
age me and Percy good for you I think
he's aging better than me no but I want
to tell you I want to tell you my my
father's cred he said nobody will ever
do anything for you you have to do
everything for yourself and do you
believe that oh I know it's true yeah I
mean even now you ask your agent to do
some well not your agent but you ask
somebody to do something and it's always
best if you do it yourself I think and
um you know you go shopping and anyway I
no I listen I know that's your man man I
see it in you every day it's incredi my
other Mantra is eat life or life will
eat you I love that love that let's hold
that thought come back after the break I
want to talk about who could be trapped
on a desert island for the rest of your
life with any of your Leading Men which
one would it be there a Cliff Hanger
[Music]
for do you know what that's exactly how
you look at me sometimes when
if I cross the line um I loved that show
and you know what I love I it fun
glamorous all of it last night I
turned on British TV on one ITV had a
Yorkshire Ripper drama BBC had a Jimmy
savel drama I was like for God's sake
just give me something I know there's
Escapist I know there's nothing
glamorous anymore it's like it's a dirty
word yeah you know I mean I was going to
wear something more glamorous than that
with a bit of glitter but then Kia St
got it for me what do you what on
politics I know you're traditionally a
conservative what what's going to happen
in this election do you think I have no
idea could you could you imagine voting
for karma no no I what about Richi well
of course I mean I but he's not my mp no
you know so I mean who knows do you
think he deserves a crack at being prime
minister a bit longer or not we've had
so many prime ministers with this
government I'd like to see Boris back oh
for God's sake Joan we've had this
conversation you can't be serious all
right well don't ask me then
um King Charles you've known him a long
time how do you think he's doing I think
he's doing fine yeah he seems to be very
lowkey you don't read a lot about him I
mean you read a lot about um Kate and
William or Katherine and William and um
you read a lot about the the Little Boy
George but you there doesn't seem to be
very much about the the king in the
newspapers or on TV I think he's doing a
good solid job from what I can say yes
hard to be exciting when you inherit it
after 70 years of waiting right well of
course I mean I missed our Queen
Elizabeth so much I mean we were so
upset when she dies even though we knew
that this was probably going to happen
and I was I remember we were playing
with our then seven-month-old baby
granddaughter sort of took our minds off
it she was just learning to crawl and um
I thought the queen was one of the most
fantastic
inspirational women ever ever I totally
agree so many times and each time I took
about it in in my book a lot how I met
her and once she had a glass when and I
was I wanted to ask her is that gin or
water but I didn't there she was great I
I once asked her about um I was it
Windor or buck P we're looking out of
the gardens and I said your majesty do
you like the the garden parties you have
to put on and she said well Mr Morgan
let me put to you like this how would
you like having 12,000 complete
strangers trampling on your lawn oh yes
you tell me that story I loved it um now
I want to show you these are five men
that you mention in your book um Marlon
Brando El it's the best name dropping
I've ever read this book even better
than mine Marlon Brando Elvis Presley
Paul Newman Richard Burton Jean Kelly if
you could be trapped Forever on a desert
island with one of them who would it be
oh well it would definitely be Paul
Newman really because he would be making
the most fabulous salad dressing and
putting it on all the leaves of all the
different trees you would be trapped on
desert island and only want to have him
make you salad dress well there would be
other things he was very Paul was very
amusing he had a great sense of humor
and he was really a word that I don't
really like nice yeah he was a just and
he fought for me to be in that movie
with him because the studio wanted Jane
mansvi and he said Jane Mansville you
know I don't want her we want Joan cuz
Joan is a good comedian and he was very
loyal and the last time I saw him was
about oh a week before he died he was
looking a little bit you know not so
well him I said how are you PJ and he
said still got a pulse which I thought
was really which in the end that's all
we can hope for isn't it I mean still
got a pulse um I tell you he also also
has a pulse I love this quote this is
from Percy at your wedding this was from
his speech Joan is my compass my comrade
my Confessor and my confident my
fearless leader and most loyal supporter
my very best friend I believe here in we
have the Arsenal to battle whatever life
has to throw at us it's my fervent wish
and my pra tonight that I can every day
in some little way make your life as
rich and wondrous as you make mine he is
a charmer person he's the best he yeah
he really is course we have our Rouse
again but he is so wonder he's a great
man you're a great lady it's been great
to see you oh it's great to your book is
called behind the shoulder pants the
tour eight more dates I think from to
New Brighton London go see it's a great
show great to see you damean uncensored
as ever and looking impossibly
glamorous